[Music]
created by logician Raymond Smolyan and
popularized by his colleague george
boolos this riddle has been called the
hardest logic puzzle ever you and your
team have crash-landed on an ancient
planet the only way off is to appease
its three alien overlords t-f and are by
giving them the correct artifacts
unfortunately you don't know who is who
from an inscription you learn that you
may ask three yes or no questions
each addressed to anyone Lord T's
answers are always true F's are always
false
and ours answer is a random each time
but there's a problem you've deciphered
the language enough to ask any question
but you don't know which of the two
words ozo and lulu means yes and which
means no how can you still figure out
which alien is which
at first this puzzle seems not just hard
but downright impossible
what good is asking a question if you
can neither understand the answer nor
know if it's true but it can be done the
key is to carefully formulate our
questions so that any answer yields
useful information first of all we can
get around to not knowing what Oso and
Lulu mean by including the words
themselves in the questions and secondly
if we load each question with a
hypothetical condition whether an alien
is lying or not won't actually matter to
see how that could work imagine our
question is whether two plus two is four
instead of posing it directly we say if
I asked you whether two plus two is four
would you answer oh so if Oso means yes
and the overlord is T it truthfully
replies ozo but what if we ask F well it
would answer Alou or no to the embedded
question so it lies and replies ozo
instead
and if oz Oh actually means no then the
answer to our embedded question is uh Lu
and both T and F still reply ozo each
for their own reasons if you're confused
about why this works
the reason involves logical structure a
double positive and a double negative
both result in a positive now we can be
sure that asking either T or F a
question put this way
will yield ozo if the hypothetical
question is true and uh Lu if it's false
regardless of what each word actually
means unfortunately this doesn't help us
with our but don't worry we can use our
first question to identify one alien
Lord that definitely isn't our then we
can use the second to find out whether
it's T or F and once we know that we can
ask it to identify one of the others so
let's begin
ask the alien in the middle if I asked
you whether the overlord on my left is
our would you answer oh so if the reply
is ozo there are two possibilities you
could already be talking to our in which
case the answer is meaningless but
otherwise you're talking to either T or
F and as we know getting ozo from either
one means your hypothetical question was
correct and the left Overlord is indeed
are either way you can be sure the alien
on the right is not R similarly if the
answer is lulu then you know the alien
on the left can't be R now go to the
Overlord you've determined isn't our and
asked if I asked are you f would you
answer
oh so since you don't have to worry
about the random possibility either
answer will establish its identity now
that you know whether it's answers are
true or false ask the same alien whether
the center Overlord is R
the process of elimination will identify
the remaining one the satisfied
overlords help you repair your ship and
you prepare for takeoff allowed one
final question you ask T if it's a long
way to Earth and he answers OHS Oh too
bad you still don't know what that means
[Music]